[Música]
una fórmula de éxito eso es lo que les
voy a contar y adivinen que gratis sin
poner un solo peso nos ayuda para
nuestra vida laboral nos ayuda para la
buena salud
adelgazar ojo mujeres para hombres
también adelgazar y hasta para retrasar
el envejecimiento la puede empezar a
usar desde ya
está
en dos palabras se las voy a decir y es
la compasión y cuando hablamos de
compasión en que pensamos pensamos en la
clase de religión que nos daban cuando
estábamos en el colegio pequeños
pensamos en jesús y si jesús tan bonito
tan compasivo pensábamos de pronto
también los budistas ay qué bonito los
budistas con su compasión o la madre
teresa tan buena la madre teresa tan
compasiva pero todo está por allá lejos
ahora todo eso de la compasión para los
filántropos multimillonarios claro cómo
tienen plata qué bueno que sean
compasivos quiero decirles que todos
ellos jesús buda la madre teresa los
millonarios filántropos no tienen ni han
tenido nunca un pelo de bobos son
inteligentísimos ellos saben que la
compasión es una fórmula que va a la fia
para tener éxito en lo que se propongan
vamos a las empresas a ser prácticos
yendo al grano directamente las empresas
que son las empresas no son los grandes
edificios tampoco son los grandes logos
ni las grandes marcas
tampoco la reputación las empresas son y
somos los empleados los empleados si los
empleados no funcionan la empresa no
funciona
si una empresa es compasiva con sus
empleados
los entiende los escucha se ponen sus
zapatos y va un paso más allá los ayuda
los empleados cómo se sienten
y cuando no se siente bien devuelve
cuando con uno se portan bien uno le dan
ganas de trabajar mejor pensemos un
poquito en nosotros cuando nosotros nos
valoran nos empoderan nos dan alas nos
dan guía clara nos muestran una visión
damos el doble acá países estratégicos
de todas las empresas y los vemos día a
día en el mundo laboral que son muy
importantes se mejoran cuando la empresa
es compasiva la retención de talento
la atracción de nuevo talento
y por tanto la productividad a mayor
motivación mayor productividad está
demostrado todos los días en el mundo
laboral lo bueno es que es contagiosa
estudios científicos recientes han
mostrado que se genera una reacción en
cadena y hablamos específicamente de los
jefes cuando los jefes son compasivos
todo lo demás fluye porque el factor
individual más importante para la
felicidad laboral es precisamente el
jefe lo demás puede estar divinamente
pero si el jefe se porta mal hasta ahí
les llega a uno la alegría de trabajar
los jefes cuando practican la compasión
hace que los empleados seamos más leales
más comprometidos queremos el doble que
trabajemos más por la empresa y eso se
ve en los resultados tienen los cuadros
de ventas entre más compasivas la
empresa tiene más posibilidad de vender
más
de hecho los mejores vendedores suelen
ser los más compasivos
es una fórmula gana gana se pone en los
zapatos de los clientes los entienden
los ayudan venden más ganan más
comisiones y los clientes que hacen se
sienten bien atendidos y devuelve a y
lealtad cosa tan difícil en este mundo
moderno la lealtad del cliente hay
recompra gana el cliente gana el
vendedor gana la empresa
empieza el efecto multiplicador cuando
el efecto multiplicador de la compasión
agarra una empresa transforma la cultura
y la cultura es hoy lo más importante el
principal factor del salario emocional
es la cultura quien no quiere trabajar
una empresa compasiva edwin negocio
pasemos a la vida personal porque les
dije que era una fórmula de éxito en
todos los aspectos en la vida personal
está demostrado varios estudios lo
corrobora que nos ayuda a la salud
número uno reduce la depresión número 2
ataca la ansiedad número 3 baja el dolor
número 4 la presión arterial se controla
número 5 sube la dopamina al subir la
producción de la dopamina en el cerebro
nos sentimos mejor nos sentimos
satisfechos nos sentimos alegres nos
sentimos mejor con nosotros mismos y
evitamos la procrastinación mal de
nuestros tiempos están aplazando y
aplazando decisiones importantes todo
eso tiene estudios científicos
además el cerebro humano funciona de una
manera muy particular
cuando el cerebro humano
da activa los mismos
centros de placer que cuando recibe
está demostrado también por la
neurociencia that nos hace tan felices
como recibir es un súper negocio y ahora
vamos a lo que les decía al principio
nos ayuda a vivir más y más sanos hoy el
secreto de la eterna juventud está en
los famosos telómeros los telómeros son
como unos pelitos delgaditos que son la
parte terminal de nuestros cromosomas de
nuestro propio adn
esos telómeros empiezan a acortarse cada
vez que crecemos que envejecemos cuando
somos compasivos logramos mantener la
longitud de los telómeros más larga
comprobado científicamente
y obviamente nos ahorramos una plática
en cremas antiarrugas no o sea está por
ahí también nos sirve para el bolsillo
la compasión para adelgazar porque
porque el estrés la ansiedad nos hace
comer más y además de hacernos comer más
nos hace sentirnos culpable por haber
comido un postrecito además entonces
entre que comemos más si nos recordamos
y que nos sentimos culpables pues no
procesamos bien la comida cuando
practicamos la compasión con nosotros
mismos la autocompasión
en ese momento nos sentimos más
tranquilos nos bajamos la ansiedad no
comemos tanto no nos castigamos y si no
nos castigamos otros estamos mejor la
comida y entre más libres nos sintamos
menos culpables menos castigados entre
menos duro nos vemos a nosotros mismos
más autocompasivo seremos y mejor
viviremos podremos darnos entonces el
lujo de probar cosas nuevas de
experimentar de hacer cosas que no nos
habíamos atrevido pero que siempre
habíamos querido y si probamos cosas
nuevas y aprendemos cosas nuevas
creceremos mejorará nuestra calidad y da
es un súper buen negocio pero además hoy
la tecnología no la pone también muy
fácil sea hoy tenemos acceso al internet
y a través del internet podemos ser
compasivos no sólo con los que tenemos
alrededor sino con gente que está muy
lejos que necesitan nuestra ayuda
plataformas como change.org plataformas
como ava citizen go han demostrado que
pueden movilizar al mundo puede
movilizarnos a nosotros desde colombia
para ayudar a cualquier persona afuera
de hecho nuestro país esas plataformas
tienen más de dos millones que mensual
de personas que mensualmente están
haciendo peticiones firmando las y
compartiendo las cada mes se crean
aproximadamente
peticiones en colombia hemos tenido
resultados también en nuestro país uno
de estos resultados es precisamente ese
un decreto anti discriminación sexual
compasión por otros seres humanos el
decreto se firmó otro compasión con los
animales este es el caso de santa marta
se volvió política pública la protección
a los animalitos de la vida de santa
marta más de 10 mil perros montones de
gatos y otros animales tienen la
protección gracias a la compasión a
través de la tecnología y no vayamos más
lejos aquí mismo en bogotá el refugio
casa san pablo 14 abuelitos hermosos
aquí en bogotá están a punto de quedarse
sin hogar y la mayoría de ellos fueron
abandonados por su familia no tenían a
dónde ir gracias a la compasión activada
vía internet estos abuelitos lograron
salvar su casa y como la compasión es
tan buena tan buena vamos a hacer en
este mismo momento
los invito a todos a cerrar los ojos
pongan los celulares abajo relájense
este momento es para ustedes
no existen preocupaciones en este
momento solo estamos acá con nosotros
mismos juegan esta música hermosa y
déjense llevar por ella y ahora
traigan en su memoria un evento de su
vida donde fueron profundamente feliz
donde se sintieron plenos tranquilos
muy muy feliz
re creerlo con el mayor detalle posible
sientan la felicidad de ese momento
nuevamente en su cuerpo hoy ahora
recorran su cuerpo con esa sensación de
felicidad
de plenitud
[Música]
y ahora con esa misma sensación con esa
misma emoción de alegría de ese momento
mágico y maravilloso proyecten en la
pantalla de su mente
a una gran multitud de personas
[Música]
y en esta gran multitud de personas
tiene ese amor que están sintiendo esa
felicidad esa alegría de ese momento tan
importante en bien
en este momento dentro de ese grupo de
personas ubiquen a una persona que
ustedes conocen y que saben que justo en
este momento está en una situación
difícil que saben que está atravesando
por dificultades y que está sufriendo
ubique la
[Música]
mentalmente
ser 15 a esa persona entre la multitud
lleguen hasta donde está
miren a los ojos
tomé la de la mano
y con todo su amor con toda su capacidad
de dar con toda su generosidad susurra
el diálogo y dos palabras hermosas que
les reconforte que le den ánimo que le
den fe le recuerden que hay esperanza
que todas las situaciones se pueden
superar que a todo en la vida se le
puede dar la vuelta
hágalo en este momento
[Música]
abracen esa persona en un abrazo
profundo generoso desde su corazón
abracen a esa persona con amor
y sientan que le están entregando todo
el confort que esa persona necesita
tranquilidad de esa persona puede
recostarse en sus brazos sentirse
confiada sentirse segura
[Música]
ahora esa persona nos mira y está las
gracias
se vuelven a ver un brillo y los ojos
esta persona que les da las gracias
emocionada porque lo que ustedes le
acaban de entregar
da un regalo valiosísimo esa persona
nuevamente tiene esperanza esa persona
ahora sabes gracias a lo que ustedes le
dieron
que tiene un camino por delante que va a
salir de esa situación tan difícil
[Música]
sientan ustedes la alegría de lo que
dieron
sientan esa felicidad que tenemos cuando
servimos a otro cuando hacemos otro
feliz
sientan la en todo su cuerpo
sin ave esa emoción que están sintiendo
ya en esa felicidad de haber dado de
haber servido es la otra persona les
agradece con el corazón
[Música]
y con esa alegría grabada en cada célula
de su cuerpo en su adn en su cerebro
vamos lentamente a volver nuevamente a
este salón a sentir nuestro cuerpo
recostado contra las sillas
y lentamente abrimos los ojos otra vez
añadido
dar
y es gratis
dar es fácil no tenemos que tener los
bolsillos llenos de dinero para dar cada
día cada día cada instante tenemos una
oportunidad valiosísima de transformar
la vida de alguien
cada día se nos da la oportunidad de ser
más buenos de ser mejores seres humanos
de ser más compasivos y cada día también
tenemos la oportunidad de que alguien
llegue a nosotros y nos transforme
también nuestra vida una sola palabra
una sola mirada una sola frase dicha en
el momento correcto nos puede a nosotros
también transformar nuestra vida
nosotros vivimos para servir vinimos a
este mundo para ser felices y como dice
el dalai lama' si queremos ser felices
seamos compasivos si queremos que otros
sean feliz seamos compasivos muchas
gracias
[Música]
a mí